Where I come from
we have a transatlantic way of seeing things
and we really don’t have any choice
because it’s a transatlantic household.
My father is from Germany
and I grew up in Germany in a small town.
My mother is from Indiana in the United States
of America
also from a small town.
We used to go visit in summer every year
and I spent the summer with my cousins.
And the would ask questions like
„Do you have electricity back in Germany?“
“Do you have TV back in Germany?”
You know, it was the ‘80s.
It really showed me from a very early age
on
that you need to explain different realities.
Look around here:
this is the heart of the European Union.
We have 28 member states
and they all have their different reality
different languages, different cultures.
When leaders of the different EU countries
gather on nights like this,
then I think there is a real need
for journalists that people trust,
that can make sense of all this
and can explain what’s actually happening
here.
It’s sort of like coming full circle
when you look at what I did when I was young.